yeah
thank you frank thanks for the
organizers and uh thanks to all of my
excellent collaborators i have five
specifically on the piece of software
that i'm going to talk about today
we decided to name it brutini real
because it's for computing real things
using bertini uh so
um
let's see so i'm going to talk today
about that which we've called brittini
reel um it's a compiled command line
software so it's not called from bertini
but it's a separate compiled piece of
software
and
it is an almost purely numerical
software package
that does a little bit of symbolic stuff
that produces a cellular decomposition
of the real algebraic component and
there's a parenthesis around that s
right there of your choosing of
the complex parts of an algebraic
variety
it's intimately connected to bertini as
the name suggests in the sense that
bertini reel uses the homotopic
continuation engine
that's from brittini
and
that's because there's adaptive multiple
precision
and a plethora of settings that
are amenable to the computations that i
do
for the few symbolic computations i do
i issue commands to matlab
i'll show you instances where i make
those by doing deflation and i've
written visualization routines and
post-processing in matlab
um
brittini reel currently will decompose
curves and surfaces dimensions uh 1 and
2.
so far i've done dimension 20 curves and
dimension eight surfaces and um if i can
overcome my own um coding ignorance i'll
be able to push those bounds even higher
yeah dimension 20 curve you need a curve
in 20 dimensional space that's right
okay yeah
do you mean
yeah john coded the iso singular
deflation in matlab and so so i call
matlab um
i would like to move entirely away from
anything that's closed source and costs
money so i'd like to use uh like senpai
as a replacement for that because then i
can give you my software and you don't
have to have matlab or maple to run it
one thing that i'm going to end with
today is that i want to show you how
i've had some
fun success in a neat application of
the decomposition that i produce which
is in the world of 3d printing so i
brought some results
okay so uh we're all about uh setting up
the notation for what we're going to do
so i'm like okay f just like you all are
doing uh polynomial system i'm assuming
i've got real coefficients and i'm going
to map from capital n to little n v is
the variety as it always is i'm going to
talk about component c
being a
component of the variety its dimension
is k
and if f happens to be over determined
that is to say that the difference
between capital n and little n is not k
then i'm just going to replace f i'm
going to forget about this one and i'm
going to replace it with a randomized
version of itself so that in all the
computations that follow i get square
systems
which is certainly necessary
and so my objective is to decompose the
real part of that complex component so
my computations are going to happen over
the complex numbers but i'm going to
find the real stuff um by uh putting my
my real number blinders on
sorry
when you say randomized version of
itself you mean just twiddle all the
coefficients by some random amount i'm
gonna take um random combinations of the
polynomials in a sensible way
so that i get a new system that square
has all of the information of the
original polynomials with the incurred
cost of um
periodically having to make sure that
the solutions i found are actually
solutions and not junk
so his rational normal curve would have
would have some random secant line on it
yeah
okay
it's a standard circle squaring up i
guess
okay so um so i'm going to tell you
about curves and i'm going to do that
first because then i'm going to use the
curved stuff to decompose surfaces um
and then i'll talk to you a bit more
about some specific polynomial systems
and how i solve those as that is the
focus of this week's workshop okay so
i'm going to produce a cellular
decomposition and
both a curve and surface decomposition
or cellular decompositions a curve is
decomposed into one cells where one is
the dimension and we call those edges
a
an edge is given in the dark blue
on the screen here it consists of two
boundary points we're calling them left
and right if you just turn your head
sideways on this line here you can go
left and right
the edge is equipped with a midpoint
which happens to be generic
i also need to know something about the
projection pi
um
and
when
the points particularly the midpoint the
left point the red point are coupled
with
the projection as well as the original
system which generated the edge or the
cell
i get the equipment i need to be able to
arbitrarily sample the
cell
by moving around the midpoint in terms
of the projection value
we're going to solve the problem by
choosing a random set of real
projections
yeah so general position is equivalent
to
choosing random projections
and it's nicer that way because that way
i don't have to muck with the
original equations i can just do
everything in terms of the
coordinates of the projection
pattern
what's the message with the curve on
this picture
so um we ask your question one more time
please which is a relationship with the
curve at your picture
the um
the curve is like
floating around behind here so it's this
is an extremely coarse representation of
the curve so i'm going to capture the
topological information of the curve
and
i'll just get this chunky representation
and the point of using this nice
representation is not only do i have
points but also a homotopy that i can
use to recover the nice smooth
representation of the curve
yeah
so so you can you can sample an arc of
the curve by moving your middle point
and fixing the right and the left points
in your curve that's right i think he
just slides
so alicia's question was from what about
the higher dimensional cells so
what do you mean by two cell
is it a regular two cell or just
homomorphic to the open ball i'll show
you in a minute
okay so it's uh because because because
in order to talk about a two cell i have
to get through the one cell stuff so i'm
gonna go through the one cell stuff and
the decomposition here's how i produce
the road map of of the curve i'm like
okay so we chose our random projections
and that's what i'm that's like
fundamental to the decomposition choose
those projections and fix them
throughout this uh it's a dimension one
object so one projection and then i'm
like okay let's find the critical points
with respect to that projection
in this case i find two
i you know like before i solve the
system i have no idea how many to expect
and then i say uh okay i've got these
points here
so let's take the centroid of those
points right there let's take three
times the distance from
the central point to the outermost
critical point that i found
triple that take a sphere of that radius
centered about those things with the
center right there intersect that with a
curve and obtain
that point and that point that's going
to capture the divergent behavior of the
curve as it goes off to infinity it's
possible that it's an intersection is
empty if the curve happens to be
real compact
so now i have essentially where all of
the interesting stuff happens it happens
where
the
curve goes
critical with respect to the random
projection and where the
curve has more or less infinite behavior
the intersection with the sphere so i
take these blue points
use my random projection and project
them onto
a position irrelevant
copy of the real line and i get these
blue checks
right there
then i take and average those this is
kind of what i think of as downstairs
and i obtain the red checks
now i take and do
a linear slice move
and obtain a slicing of the curve above
each of these midpoint projection points
and i get these red points right
here things are starting to pencil in
here
so now my objective is to
um to complete the road map i've got the
generic points in the middle those are
going to be these red points right here
i've got the end points of the edges or
at least some of them the rest have yet
to manifest so then i'm going to take
for each red point
i'm going to track it left and right
and see where it goes on that curve i'm
going to use that homotopy that i'm
equipped with which was the
function for the curve itself i'm going
to track it and i'm going to see to
which of the blue points does it go
or maybe it doesn't go to a blue point
and it just kind of stops and it's a
point that i haven't encountered before
and i just say okay it's a new point and
i'm still going to create the edge so i
get as a result of doing that this
overly complicated decomposition of this
elliptic curve so if you get the if you
get it where it stops then there was a
critical point you didn't detect no the
critical point in this in this
particular picture right here um the
critical point that i didn't detect that
you think i didn't detector down here
but they lie in the same
fiber of the projection as this
intersection point with the sphere
i guess what i was saying is you follow
these red points and sometimes you get
your glute point you said sometimes you
don't so if you don't get to a blue
point then that must mean there's a
critical point you didn't detect it just
means that it's in the same fiber as a
critical point okay yeah observe oh i
see i i understand okay okay groovy
yeah so so these are kind of superfluous
points they shouldn't have shown up
uh they're just kind of like these
artifacts to the point that in that same
fiber there was a legitimate critical
pointer intersection point and so as
optional step five if you want to get
something that's kind of topologically
simple um we're going to merge away
these guys i'm going to say okay so this
guy was new i remember that i remember
the property that's associated to it
some metadata and now i can take
one of these two
points here it doesn't matter which one
track it to halfway between this blue
point and this blue point and simplify
this edge so that now i have the cyan
edge this yellow edge and this one right
here so
now i've got a simple one again this
step is optional you can stop right here
and now
the part that our eyes really like
or possibly that
numerical integration over this thing or
maybe optimization likes is the ability
to refine this curve by sliding around
the midpoint of each edge by controlling
its projection value and i can
do that so long as i don't attempt to
track the midpoint beyond either of the
endpoints of the edge on which it lies
that's a curve decomposition for me
and it works
in any computationally feasible
dimension
so here's our friend the twisted cubic
this non-merged
overly complicated decomposition has
five edges
okay so i plotted all the points here
i used an um an over determined
representation of the twisted cubic two
to show you that it works even in the
case that i use
something which requires randomization
here's a curve
this is a critical curve of a chmutav
surface which is
a sum of
chebychev polynomials and variables
i like to think of it as swiss cheese
all right so here's a here's my my
critical curve on my block of swiss
cheese
it's still it's it's a three-dimensional
curve so it's not that bad
um there are pre-existing algorithms
okay and then here's um the second
largest curve that i've decomposed uh
which charles showed earlier thank you
very much for the plug
which is in uh 14 variables um and the
two
two dimensional projection we're viewing
right here degree 128 um and in an old
um
less optimized version took
uh like 12 hours or something like that
to decompose it wasn't bad
okay so now i'm ready to answer your
your question about what the two cell
looks like okay so here's um part of a
decomposition i always like to show it
as as part of a decomposition because by
itself it makes less sense so for me
a 2 cell
consists of a generic midpoint always
have one of those guys why because i
want to be able to refine this and then
it's got boundary so it's got a generic
point in the middle a boundary it's
going to have two projections and a
system that i can use to sample it the
boundary is going to consist of
a left edge which came from a curve
decomposition a right edge in this case
it was degenerate the right mid and left
points of that edge were all the same
and a top and a bottom edge of which
there can be only only one per top and
bottom
and they're all glued together
does that answer your question about
what the two cell looks like
tonight's
the high dimensions
this is a this is a um a
three-dimensional surface that i'm
showing a piece of right here and so the
red block is one
there's one face i've got another face
or another two cell right here we call
it we call it two cells faces
um so i got a yellow one a blue one red
one
it's easy to get a lot of them in a
decomposition so how do i how do i
produce my cellular decomposition into
two cells which contain one cells as
boundaries which contain points or zero
cells as boundaries
yes
okay so first i'm going to decompose the
critical curve i'm going to examine now
i have two projections because i'm
decomposing a two-dimensional object
so i'm going to find where is the
surface critical with respect to those
two projections get this critical curve
there may also be singular curves
anything that's singular is naturally
going to appear when you do the critical
curve decomposition in order to do that
i need to lie on john's iso singular
deflation algorithm and that's where the
matlab comes in
since virtini doesn't have symbolics
inside of it i'm like okay i'll turn to
one of these other guys so i do an iso
singular deflation so here's the handle
of the whitney umbrella boom pops up
it's deflated i can track on it it's
decomposed into edges and okay then i'm
intersecting with the sphere to capture
that infinite behavior
i'm going to
slice in between all of the critical
stuff and i get
mid slices like this thin one right here
i get critical slices like the thicker
ones
and then i need to connect the dots
connect the midpoints of the face to the
midpoints of all the adjoining edges to
the left and right
and
i call it connect the dots right here so
i get this chunky representation of the
whitney umbrella
and then since i have generic midpoint
projections and homotopy i can refine it
ad nauseam and i get a refined whitney
umbrella
so um it sounded like frank earlier was
curious as to what makes this different
um for me a zero dimensional set like
this singular curve is zero dimensional
it's um it has uh
no
positive measure to it in the sense that
um
a
uh
bisection method would when you descend
and bound it between boxes so i can
truly detect that zero dimensional stuff
is zero dimensional
okay so here's an example of what the
torus looks like for me i get um eight
faces on this guy where the critical
curve are the two boundaries
i've got this uh still three dimensional
surface i've got this surface right here
which has two curves of singularity a
self intersection and a cusp where both
of those curves happen to go naked for a
little while i've got this four
dimensional surface reviewing a
three-dimensional projection of it
i've got this
three-dimensional projection of a
six-dimensional surface uh it's been
passed through an arc tangent to
function in order to obtain a periodic
uh
surface so you could glue the two ends
of the worm together and you get kind of
this infinite chain of worms
okay um
do they have any additional properties
are they cylindrical
um
they are
um a breaking up of the surface into
the the boundaries which are
critical in terms of the two projections
that you've chosen and regions interior
to those which are
generic and singularity free
does that answer your question
well i know that
we have been trying to
obtain cellular decomposition
of two-dimensional surfaces but we fix
coordinate system not with random and
it's kind of rather difficult so i'm
thinking well
okay
i got a few minutes left here so i'm
gonna
place forward okay so i've got um i rely
wholly on on the witness set and on the
regeneration that charles talked about
earlier today to solve these systems
you're like dan uh
how do you get these blue points that
were on the elliptic curve at the
beginning how do you get that critical
curve and i'm like oh i just find where
the determinant of the jacobian matrix
concatenated with the jacobian of the
random projection or maybe you chose a
special projection that's an option to
the program
go singular and then i have some patch
equation uh which sometimes i write and
sometimes i don't
uh that one shouldn't have one there so
how do i how do i solve that i solve
that by
um doing a regeneration to the system on
the right right here and i solve the
system on the left so i've got these
null vector variables right here i've
got this matrix right here i've got the
patch to make sure i don't just find the
zero null vector which you're not
interested in and i repeatedly move my
witness linear to the linears on the
right right here
make sure i have the appropriate number
of them
have these m's right here so that every
point i start with when i do this
homotopy
satisfies the condition that this system
vanishes
move from t equals one to t equals zero
and
boom
solve that solve that critical system
um
so uh
you also need to have critical points on
the critical curve and for me this is
the most challenging step of the of the
program in the sense that i have nested
determinate jacobian operations so
right here is the equation for the
critical curve i've got this linear
right here to emphasize the fact that um
any points i get on it are going to come
equipped with a linear as well since
they're going to be witness points
and in order to find the critical points
of the critical curve i've got to
incorporate um this beast into my system
so i've got to do regeneration to this
thing right here
so it's going to be high degree it's
going to have a greater density of
monomials than i started with is
generally
generally unpleasant to to try to solve
that system
so that's why britini is super awesome
because it's got the adaptive multiple
precision and a number of other features
that allow us to actually tackle stuff
which tends to be
nasty to track
so this equation right here
to me suggests the recursive nature of
the algorithm if i wanted to decompose
a threefold
and then i would have determine of
jacobian of determinative jacobian of
determinant of jacobian which i don't
think my computer is up to uh solving so
we're going to have to find some tricks
to get around this nested
dejac
condition
um so uh the part that uh has been super
pleasant for me has been the 3d printing
on my surface uh in which i um first run
bertini so that gives me the witness
sets i run bertini reel i get my
decomposition i refine it um that's a
separate compiled program
process it through matlab into a stereo
lithography file
and because you can't print something
that's infinitely thin
i've tried it and you just get junk
let's give that let's give that guy some
thickness i typically use the
free python implementation blender to do
that and then i send that to a printer
which ends up being surprisingly hard so
i brought
that particular decomposition
and the refined form today i've got this
this came off of a makerbot at nc state
i've also got a copy of the solitude uh
which was printed on a youprint using a
dissolvable filament
so that we don't have nasty interface
with the
support material and um i brought a
little tray of whitney umbrellas so
yeah you got to keep i actually want to
print a really big one and like carry it
around when it's raining at notre dame
and see all the weird looks like it
because it would be it's totally
ineffective
as an umbrella or maybe it'd be a good
two-person umbrella and you stand side
by side
yeah huh
yeah
it would if if i could just get the dye
for my pasta machine that made this i'd
be a happy man it's pretty close to a
bow tie
so i brought about 20 whitney umbrellas
and uh one little ice shoot guy
so
i'm giving a talk in about two weeks at
san francisco state where i'm going to
talk specifically about some of the
issues with trying to print something
that's impossible to print
so if you happen to be at that
conference you might consider coming and
checking out what i have and with that
it will conclude thank you so much
so i know that you say that you have
certified computations but my question
is you already knew the form of you you
knew that you needed this part of the
umbrella of small dimension or you just
pop out really without knowledge it um
it pops out without knowing it so in in
the step let me let me back up just a
little bit right here so in the step
where i obtained the um the witness
points for this
some of those witness points are going
to have multiplicity greater than one or
be singular i detect that and i feed
those points into an iso-singular
deflation algorithm and i get a
different deflation sequence and a
different polynomial system for every
singular curve that appears as part of
the surface
um this surface right here um is a
four-dimensional surface and it has
three curves of singularity to it each
having a different deflation
um so it it's almost like magic that
that they show up um yeah so i i'm
absolutely ignorant before i begin the
decomposition that such a singularity
exists i just wait for it to appear when
i find the witness points for the curve
and then
feed them into this with a different f
namely the deflated one for each of the
singular curves
you're welcome
any other questions yes
when you you use the hormone to be
continuation method so over the complex
number you have to avoid the
discriminant locals and you can because
it has two dimension two over the real
but if you work over the rear how you
can avoid this discriminant which has
got dimension one
that's a that's a very good question so
are are you most con
in which part of the algorithm are you
most concerned about
this is a general that
all times that you use a homotopy and
you have to care about this problem so i
i
that's that's a really good question and
my brief answer to it is that i stay in
the complex world as long as possible i
just kind of hang out in complex until
the last moment i duck into the reels
and at that point i forget about the
complexes so
the the answer to your question is that
to obtain witness points um i do
everything over the complex numbers so i
have like random slice of random complex
slices and stuff like that
um and the initial
objects would be complex that's right
and you would drive them to real objects
i drive them to the real object yeah so
for example in the step where
i
i do the slice right here
i do that by moving from a
a complex linear to the particular
it looks like a real linear but it's
really a statement about the projection
value in terms of one of the projections
and at that point i've only done that
once and then later i actually do track
on the real stuff
and that's in the step where i connect
the dots and it's a very special
homotopic that's been constructed in
that i track simultaneously on the top
edge the bottom edge and the midpoint in
a way such that i couple the two
projection values so that i don't
accidentally cross the boundary
in terms of the criticality of the
projection value it's a very special
homotopia and it's
um it's fairly time consuming in the
sense that you're tracking like
approximately
um five times the number of variables
you started with if not more
but and that's that's not if you're
tracking on um on the critical curve uh
um
but i think also also
you only go you only go between these
critical points that's right
you avoid them by just your choice of
not going to the critical point
these these two steps right here if you
get these wrong if you if you fail to
pick up a critical point then i'm going
to encounter the problem that you're
talking about because i'm going to try
to track across the criticality or
singularity
that exists but i didn't know it was
there and then things are totally gonna
break down and the decomposition has
holes in it and it's all jagged and the
program complains
um so it's it's sensitive to the choices
that you make for the settings in
bertini it's extremely sensitive you
have to choose uh
a higher security max norm if you're if
you're into monitoring the
size of your variables so that you can
quit tracking infinite paths sometimes
things look like they're going to be
infinite but they're not they're not
going to be infinite those are just in
the synthetic variables and and the real
ones are still finite so it's it's
tricky there's issues all over the place
yeah i've heard there's all kinds of
difficulties with your printing what 3d
printer defines the best for doing all
three varieties
i i personally that was a very good
question maurice i have personal
experience with um with one printer
being the operator and with two being a
bystander and letting undergrad operate
it for me and the best experience i've
had so far was on the uprint operated by
an undergrad because it could print a
dissolvable support
um whereas the machine that john bought
right now i have a lulzbot test for
um and we got it like three weeks ago
and um
and i i asked it to do things it wasn't
designed to do
is hard man bridging's hard and and
trying to i know we're over time i'll
you should talk to me afterwards i'm
very excited about it thank you so much
it's important that we get moving
because i think jm has a lecture